[Music]
back when we had winners
i was afraid to lose you to the
competition
five times you won the all-american that
was a long time ago wasn't it
that was before the accident before the
booze
you know how many people told me to just
cut you loose
[Music]
you gonna say anything howard i've
always thought of you as a small
weak and gutless man but you know
there's no reason to be rude
you owe me mike you gave me your word
and that used to mean something my son
rafael
he's in trouble i want to get him out of
mexico
we want you to go down there and kidnap
him please
just get him back up here yes you just
me
[Music]
here after you come out now i'm a friend
of the family
touch me and kick your hustle man jesus
christ
[Music]
get in the back we go and i tell you
okay
look the only place you're gonna go is
the hospital you get too angry it's not
good for you
[Music]
you used to be strong natural
i used to be a lot of things but i'm not
now
[Music]
i'll tell you something this macho thing
is
overrated
just people trying to be macho show that
they've got grit
[Music]
that's about all they end up with
it's like anything else in life you
think you got all the answers
i'm mike
[Music]
and you realize as you get older you
don't have any of them
we all have to make choices in life kid
you have to make yours
[Music]
his name is macho like me very strong
rooster
whatever what's wrong with that nothing
guy wants to
name this cart macho it's okay by me
[Music]